rising empires turn your biz into a
brand Jared bro I'm so thankful you
helped me come up with silver as a name
but I'm even happier that you steered me
away from our old logo yeah I remember
that was an interesting chat Jared and
not reminisced about their early talks
on logos dude Silve is an epic brain
it's the Porsche of landscape but your
current logo is like slapping an ugly
bumper sticker on it back then Jared and
Matt were having a deep chat trying to
take his brain to the next level but
Matt was fighting tooth and nail against
changing the logo logos fine I'm
actually pretty proud of it Matt
responded but mostly on autopilot it was
clear to Jared Matt didn't have any real
education on top - your logos man it's
cluttered blurry when shrunk
there's too many colors and they don't
even get him Vince made it Vince the guy
Jer had accidentally insulted was Matt's
close friend and business partner oops
okay Vince put in a lot of love I
respect that
but is that logo ready for a global
stage yes I don't see why not
come on look at him be honest I stand by
it
don't push me on this Jared bit his lip
closed his eyes and looked as if he
vibrate off the earth
okay man it's been a good run I feel you
I'm gonna move on other projects and
wish you luck in the next visit
accelerator we what really yeah it's a
shame we had such opposite views in this
key area and I remember that moment so
clearly imagine if I actually pushed
he'll go away yeah that was rough
Matt left the convo feeling terrible but
it couldn't put his finger on why he
knew his loca was awesome wasn't it yeah
definitely he was in the right here but
he couldn't sleep that night he tossed
and turned having to admit a hard truth
he knew that Jarrod's advice on naming
his company was spot-on
he was attaching his logo for
sentimental reasons and they'd likely
make scaling his brand tough Jared was
trying to help the right thing to do was
to reach out and clear things up Jared
I'm sorry for any misunderstandings
I thought deeper about it and I'm open
to any advice you have on the logo if
you still look for sharing the moment
the email was sent Matt got a Skype call
awesome so glad you changed your mind
ready for the tips
yeah totally site thank you okay first
let's look at some amateur logos
together these are mostly uninspiring
limited scale logos that won't survive
in the wild yeah I can see that now
let's look at some epic frames these are
symbols of vision and legacy apex
predators just having them displayed
lens automatic prestige I love it so how
do I get that it's a blend of a few key
principles such as simplicity for one
all these logos are quite simple this
makes them easy to reproduce a kid can
scratch it into a desk at school or the
symbols simple enough to be laser etched
into jewelry got it so mine isn't simple
enough what else
scalability your local pretty much needs
to fill a square or a circle no long
rectangles for towering verticals this
lets it fit on every product every ad it
allows your symbol to be used by artists
as an icon
paper banner sign etc ooh yikes
mine definitely can't do that yeah and
that's not all let's talk about contrast
your colors have to pop and rarely more
than one or two and more than that your
logo should pop even in black and white
otherwise it just won't work in many
mediums ebooks low-budget prints and
single color tees for example okay but
hold on these colors have a lot of
meaning they send the right message
about silk the green is for earth blue
is but water the yellows or Sun these
three pillars of a foundation of our
landscaping philosophy I'd rather not
throw them away yep it's common for
peeps to get attached to their colors so
let me ask you this is it humanly
possible to do everything you said with
less colors can we send a message with
the icon itself rather than just
sticking a bunch of colors on it I mean
I guess then let's do it a logo that
can't perform in black and white is lazy
and you'll pay for it down the road I
mean man you're hardcore well you don't
have to do all this I'm just trying to
pave the way for brand growth many
brands evolve their logo after years of
building brand equity and it's insanely
expensive for them to do that if they
had me clarifying things from the
beginning they would have saved a lot of
trouble I get it I get it
please continue okay so where was I oh
yeah timeless iconic unique your local
ideally isn't confused with other brands
so I'm guessing the stock leaf in ours
isn't great yeah look at Nike Apple or
McDonald's for instance distinct and
unmistakable right ah so silk can still
have a leaf in it it just can't look
like other brands what's next next we
get trickier what dude this is tricky
enough honestly man my head is spinning
I'm not an artist I can't do this you
make a good point there's something to
be said for hiring a professional but
surely you know the story of Nike
getting their logo dirt cheap from an
intern right yeah that sounds like a
dream come true let's do that sure
winning a lot
feels great too but is it a reasonable
strategy Plus Nike later realized it
wasn't fair to not compensate properly
so they went back and gave the intern
significant shares in the company yeah I
guess look at it this way even if you
don't make your own logo at least you'll
be armed with the right wisdom you'll
know how to guide your designers you'll
know what designs to keep or trash
knowing what makes a world-class brand
is a skill worth having and you're
getting part of it right now hmm okay
I'm with you let's keep going
while Jared talked Matt pulled out a pen
and grabbed the napkin off his table
okay good because the next ones are a
bit special logos should be contextual
responsive and use the golden ratio what
does that even mean context means your
logo fits in with all the rest of your
brand's look and feel Disney can have a
cartoony word mark because all that
content is kid focused cartoon vibes
Nike can have a movement focused swoosh
because all their content around it is
also things in motion hmm so silts logo
should hit between natural aesthetics we
have elsewhere got it
what about responsive responsive pretty
new
now that society has millions of
different sizes tablets laptops and
phones you want your logo to be dynamic
able to morph from full logo with the
word lurk down to a tiny flat icon
depending on screen size you may even
want it to animate like Google's cool
and I already know what the golden ratio
is you do sure present everywhere in
nature from petals to branches the
galaxies we use it often in silk
landscapes no point by discussing it
then true but you're such a smartypants
let me show off that I finally know
something about logos awesome go for it
you basically won all your sections
divided into two unequal yet balanced
parts yeah as a decent summary there's
some precise math involved but generally
it creates a spiral of balanced units
you can see it here in the Twitter logo
so is all of this making sense so far it
really is and I can see how mastering
all these would put me way ahead of most
brands
I'm sharing some hesitation it's just
that what they make the logo up people
say my logo has to have meaning so I've
got to jump through all these hoops and
that'll make it meaningful that's why
most people don't have world-class logos
that's the challenge your logo is meant
to be eternal ammo for your army of
things from preteens to pensioners they
will do a ton of your marketing for you
spreading the word of it selves through
art tattoos sponsorships and more but
only if you give them something worth
showing off it's not hard physically
it's a few lines on a screen you're more
than capable of doing it though it may
take a few tries but you're not alone
like I said before you can get an intern
or hire a designer you can crowdsource
logos on 99designs
you can even invest in a branding house
who in my mind aren't usually worth it
but they'd likely understand all the
tips we've just covered but I know bro
there are exceptions there are brands
that succeed by breaking one or more of
these rules but generally the more of
these tips you apply the higher chance
you have of succeeding wow man
thank you I get it you just need you
decades of ineffective branding Matt
raison napkin he'd be scribbling on with
a grin wow you really took the lessons
to heart Matt you're totally on the
right track
that's almost good enough as is Matt
bowed low but felt this heart soar he
had in his hand a precious symbol for a
new era and SILS future look very very
bright Wow he's come a long way since
then yeah man huge congrats you hundred
percent deserve all your success Thanks
I never dreamed our logo would be a
badge of honor but it would help down
the clothing line Matt took the time
care to create a truly epic logo one
that did a lot of heavy lifting for his
brain and your logo can do the same for
you if you give your customers a
valuable symbol that's really worth
sharing
rise and boobies
now turistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think unseen
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want more empire building tips check
out the first video in this series on
how to pick a winning business name the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there Matt wanted to help a
lot of people he believed that
beautifying the environment maids life
on earth better